hi there today we'll look at
singularitynet the global ai marketplace
as it is advertised on their website um
specifically we're going to look at the
singularitynet whitepaper 2.0
as it appeared in 2019 so it's version
version two
version one i think appeared in 2017. so
singularitynet
is a as it says a global a marketplace
but it is also
kind of an effort it is a foundation it
has blockchain in it
it has ai in it it has symbolic
computation it has graphs it has
all the things all the buzzword you
could possibly
want so the high level summary of this
system is that it is a marketplace
for apis basically on blockchain
where either humans or apis can call
other apis
and pay them for that service and the
goal is to sort of get
a network going of apis that call apis
that call
apis and sort of have that built into
a global ai not only marketplace but
like as itself a global ai this is
backed by the singularitynet foundation
and they do a whole bunch of development
of the platform but also research on
the platform and we'll look at all of
this today so it is a
white paper which is not a research
paper as we usually look at
that means a bunch of things first of
all as you can see it's quite long
and we're going to skip most of it
actually
um but also i have maybe it's just
it's just because it's a white paper and
that's usual but
this all of this is it's sort of
marketing
and it's it's it's sort of never fixates
on
one level of analysis like it goes into
this and then a bunch of buzzwords and
then
super detail and then it talks about you
know what kind of cache do we need for
the database but then
it goes back and it just references a
bunch of stuff without explaining it
uh to just kind of beef it up for
investors i guess
i don't know in any case um we're going
to go through it we're going to go
through
what the marketplace looks like how it
works
um what it's good for or some of my
criticisms
um the the central components as i said
are the apis
but also a rating system and
it is also decentrally governed so the
goal is to have the community govern the
network
and lastly the goal is to have all of
this
be beneficial for humanity
um so
we're gonna see how this all uh ties
together
so what's the the current the current
situation and what the singularity net
want to do
so let's say you are this external
software
you're a person okay and what you want
to do
is you want to summarize a document
the view that this system has is that
you could give this
to a document summarizer the document uh
summarizer however um looks at this
and sees oh what are you giving me
you're giving me
and in this case it might be you know an
article of the new york times that has
both text
and video okay so you give it you you
see an article
it has like a title it has a bunch of
text and here it has like a little video
to go along with it
and you simply say summarize this to me
so
this document summarizer all it does is
it looks at the document and it sees up
there is a bunch of text
and there is a video here and i'm going
to
uh so in order to summarize the document
i need to
summarize the text and i need to
summarize the video
so it will take the text and it will
send it
to a node that's dedicated only to text
summarization
and then it will send the video to a
note that's only dedicated to video
summarization the video summarizes
summarizer in turn
could do stuff like call face
recognizers
and call some databases in order to sort
of get
who is in the video or what's in the
video you could call object detection
and so on
the text summarizer in turn it could
call
some word sense disambiguators it could
call entity extractors to also
realize what is in the document and then
these nodes will
send sort of so every node
can call other nodes in the network and
at the bottom
you'll have these sort of ai primitives
um like face identification
entity extraction and so on and they are
not
to be meant to be called by you directly
they're meant to be called by
higher level nodes that sort of
aggregate them
okay and this now if you look at this
and if you are a software developer
you you think of libraries like you
think of course
um you know this is this here this stuff
here is
maybe that's hogging face and this stuff
here probably in spacey
that exists right if you are a software
developer
you know if you have to do subtasks
someone probably already solved that
subtasks i can just call a library
now the view of singularitynet is that
no maybe you don't want to call a
library
maybe you don't know yet what's the best
so their view is a marketplace and
why is a marketplace better for ai than
for regular programs um because
you know for regular programs we don't
need a marketplace we simply
call a library why is that not good for
ai
i'm you know i'm trying to i'm trying to
sort of
make sense of this right here i'm not
convinced by this system either but i'm
sort of
trying to make the best case for it that
i can
so if you are this let's go back to that
graphic
if you are this text summarizer
and you need to do you need to do entity
extraction
right you might have a lot of a lot of
choice so there might be
you know entity entity extractor
a there might be entity extractor b
and so on there might be many of these
entity extractors and then a new paper
comes out
right and then entity extractor
f is somewhere on github you know but
so what you need to do every time a new
entity extractor
comes out is released you know someone
makes a paper maybe put some code the
code doesn't really work you have to go
fetch that code you have to
look you have to plug this into your
system right
you have to test against your data sets
and you have to decide is this better
than
what i had before or is it worse is it
worth
including and so on so
it is in the in the classic software
world
if you have a library that does
something it does that thing right
it cannot necessarily do it better or
worse
however in the machine learning world it
can definitely be you know that this
thing here is like
90 percent accurate which is already
good but then something comes out
with 95 accurate and that's better and
you would like
to sort of switch to the better thing or
the thing that
meets your needs more the thing that
works on your test data set
and so on so that's sort of the case to
be made for an
ai marketplace now
this singularity net's vision is that
let's say
i'm a researcher i come up with a new
entity extractor
right um i have my so i have my paper
here i have it written i have
maybe a bit of code somewhere
what i can do is i can plug this into
singularitynet
right and then i am say here here
i am entity extractor x and you can
advertise yourself
to this network and then all the other
nodes
like this text summarizer node but you
know many other nodes
could then come and sort of in an
automated fashion
test some sort of test data set that
they have
against you right they test it against
your system
and they can evaluate you and then they
will switch
to you to using your code if you are
better than the competition for them
or maybe if you're cheaper right and for
that if you're a researcher and do all
that
for that you would get money because
every time a node
calls you they're giving you some money
for
analyzing their data so that is the
that is the sorry that is the
the core idea behind the ai
marketplace right here so the ai
marketplace
as a whole looks something like this
and there's a lot of stuff here
uh but we'll go through it sort of one
by one
okay so it is so this
this here it mixes kind of conceptual
and technical
and so on um but ultimately
you have is there a way i can
draw this more easily
um
yeah maybe okay so you have consumers
okay and consumers can be people
or can be robots and
you have a whole network of them right
and the robots if if it's a robot
the robot exposes an api as we said
the robot exposes an api that says
exactly what
inputs it takes and what outputs it
provides and it can also do tags so here
are my inputs here are my outputs and it
can you can have some tags it can
for example say hey i am an entity
extractor
um my you know i do it i do entity
extraction in
english and and so on though maybe the
english would actually go into the into
the input definition so we could
do entity extraction so the input
definition says i need
a string that's called text
and that string needs to be
language english
and for that i can produce a set
of a list of entities
entity something like this okay
it is very much like you would specify
an interface in in regular
programming except that um in
singularitynet
these types here so the string um
with the language parameter and like the
the definition of what an entity is
they are i don't want to say centrally
because it's a it's on a blockchain but
in essence they are
on the blockchain centrally deposited
you can add your own
but you can also um implement
the the ones that other people have
already defined and what would be the
good thing about not defining your own
well if if this is the kind of commonly
agreed upon
standard for entity or
entity recognition did i say
augmentation
extraction entity extraction i said
i put an a all the time sorry about that
if this is the
common definition for entity extraction
and you implement the same right you
have your new algorithm over here
and you implement the same api you know
you have this this green api and you
implement the same types
then anyone who uses this api
can if they want switch without any work
to your api and if you are better
then you know you get probably their
business because they want to call the
better one
the idea of singularitynet actually goes
further because
this is not only callable by humans this
is also callable by
other robots so here i have a other
robot
and this is a special robot because this
robot is like an evaluator robot
so this robot can go around and it has a
little
data set inside of it and it will just
do nothing else but
scan for new ais on the network that
implement a certain api it will
recognize and it will say ah
this is the this is the api for entity
recognition
or entity extraction i will simply run
my test data set
against it and i will run my test data
set against this and so on and i will
report so my api
will be i simply output
i simply so input would be
a task name so task it would be a string
or something like this
and the output
would be a list
of model and performance like model a
model m 90
model x 95
okay so there could there can be
robots that test other robots
and then publish sort of ranking lists
and then
i as a like i as a human or
the the robot you know the the higher
order robots
they can go read this robot
and then decide to which of the of the
all the
listed and uh things they want to go so
at central core to this system is this
kind of shared type system
if you share the types if you share the
apis
your apis become replaceable with one
another and therefore you can enable
sort of automatic
competition and automatic matchmaking so
these robots the they're evaluator
robots and there are matchmaker robots
where you can tell a robot i would like
to extract some entities
please find me the best node in the
network that does it
okay and the marketplace makes sense
because it's
ai and it constantly shifts which one is
good and which one's appropriate
that's the best case i can make for it
like i have my doubts that this is
actually the case
like uh but we'll get to well actually
no let's make the case against it so my
case against
uh the ai marketplace as it is listed
here is twofold
so first first point against it
everything we know right now
is end to end um the direction of
research
is clearly going into less structured
data
and more end to end that means if i want
to do
a text summer or a document summarizer
i am right now much better off uh
just training a giant model that does it
end to end
rather than using many many small models
because
if if i call an entity extractor right
and i simply only rely on that
information i
lose the the rest of the text and the
nuances in the text i simply get the
output of that model now i could
combine that of course but um this this
idea of
modularizing ai i'm right now
research is pointing into a different
direction and second of all
i still believe um like i if i
make a product if i build a product
towards a user
i want to know what's in it like even if
i have to go with myself and test the
stupid ap i would never use like a
matchmaking
agent that dynamically goes and finds me
someone who can implement this api
because implementing an api only goes so
far
implementing you know like i require
image and i
output value that's an api but
that can be many and then you know maybe
these tags here
maybe these tags could do something but
it is not like i think the system
even though it's you know um thought out
well with the types and the apis and so
on
i don't think that's enough i think that
works for a very very small subset of ai
tasks i don't think that works
for most of the ai tasks that we have
right now because
simply api definitions just don't convey
what the models so wait api
so api does not convey
what the model does function
in my mind so i would ask yourself if
you would if you were there to use a
matchmaking agent
and then you know sell that product to a
customer
it's it's shady but i guess the goal
here is that in the future
these matchmaking agents will be much
more
intelligent and so on yeah so here is
how it works on a more
sort of technical level so there is two
components here there's off chain
and on chain so if uh i'm assuming you
know
what a blockchain is if you don't know
what a blockchain is a
blockchain is basically a distributed
database and
in some forms also a computation engine
so it's kind of a distributed
computer that um you can't fake
so you can't cheat no one has authority
over it
everything is visible and so that's
secure the drawback is you cannot do
hardcore computation on blockchain so
this
is not ai on blockchain the blockchain
is simply there
to first of all register the ais so
register the types so this this apis
here
and register what ais are available in
the network
and second of all to facilitate the
payments to the ai
so how does that work um it goes via
this
sort of multi-party escrow escrow
contract
right here so there's the registry by
the way that's where ai's register
and put their types so that's one
function of the blockchain
the other function is to escrow money
and this
if you know lightning network is very
similar to this
so what you would do if i don't know
alice
uh wants to call bob um
alice would sort of put a bunch of money
like a
a big bunch of money how do i do that uh
alice would send money to this escrow
account like this much money
and then that establishes a channel
between alex
uh alice sorry and bob so there is a
channel
channel is opened and it's tied to this
money
and now alice can sort of send
incremental amounts of that money
to bob and every time you know one of
these
like a little bit of that money is used
up and the way
the reason you do it in escrow form and
not
so all of these could be transactions on
the blockchain right
but that's first of all it's slow and
second of all it's expensive
and if you do it like this you actually
only
need at you know you need one
transaction in best case so if alice
spends this much
money to bob there needs to be only one
transaction
um to putting all of it to bob at the
same time rather than all these
small transactions so that's kind of the
the channel principle
i think yeah it's very similar to
lightning network and it's
still secure so there it's still secure
the way it is done um don't want to go
into uh
channel economics and security right
here but
suffice to say you can make this secure
and fast to a certain degree
okay so that's how it works every time
you call
an api you just send it some money
in order to call it so how does this
look this looks something like
this sorry here is this ai marketplace
they've actually
built it and they have a bunch of
services on there
as you can see it's you know it's it's
kind of they
they take some standard ai tasks and
they put them
on here and if you click on one
you can either you know pay agi tokens
um that's the thing we're going to get
to in a second or
you i think you have like 10 free calls
a day if you make an account so i've
tried it out
you know it works but
it's important to realize that the
computation
does not happen on the blockchain you
send money on the blockchain
and the ai service it runs
off chain so this is off chain okay
so it is not a secure ai
you still need to trust the thing you're
calling
right um it's not about
privacy that much but you you can't
verify
the outputs you can't verify the
computation as you could if
if it were happening on chain now there
are methods to sort of
do heavy computation on chain but these
i guess wouldn't be that
efficient um so just
take that in mind now the other thing is
i always send say
you send around money uh but what you
actually send around is
a token so a token is a very special
concept
um if you if you don't know what a token
is
it's like money on top of money so it's
like if you go to a fair
and the fair has like its own internal
money system
at the beginning you you pay like 20
bucks and you get a hundred
fair coins and you can use the fair
coins inside the fare and that just
enables the fare
to sort of have its own monetary policy
and it's usually done with these
projects to at the very beginning
you sort of sell those coins to a lot of
people and the people buy it
not because they can use it right there
but they estimate they can use it later
and it's a way to
found a project it's called an it's
called an
initial coin offering usually or initial
token uh
offering the coin that singularity net
uses is
aptly called agi and um
there is one billion and you can
see here it's still active so it's still
being traded you can see this is an hour
ago
2015 minutes ago and so on if you look
at
here is analysis if you look at the
activity on the network it had a lot of
activity at the beginning
it dropped and now it picked up a little
bit again
um i don't know exactly what that's
related to
but so it is still alive
if you look at the price however uh this
sharply dropped and is now actually
below the price
of the initial coin offering and what
you hope
when you you know buy the initial coin
is not only that you can use it later
but
you know that since there is only
limited amount of tokens
that that will be more valuable in the
future
um because people want to buy it off you
because they want to use the network
here it sort of looks like that's not
exactly happening
and we'll get to what they're doing
against it uh
right in a second the answer is
inflation
um so in a new blog post actually as i
was preparing for this video this new
blog post came out
uh yesterday and um
here they're announcing sort of the path
forward
uh singularitynet phase two and
essentially what they're doing is
they're switching blockchains from
ethereum to cardano and i have my doubts
isn't kurt like i don't know much about
this whole the whole
crypto uh space but isn't cardona where
massive amounts of the
of the coins are like in some
i i think there are massive amounts that
are just never moved and so on and
and it's quite scary uh but
you know they probably know what they're
doing
um and with that they are doubling the
amount of tokens like they could do it
without uh
increasing the tokens but with that
they're issuing another billion
um tokens i think 50 or 25 percent
will go to themselves so that's usually
you do that in initial coin offering
right you keep some of the
tokens uh to yourself because
as people buy it it's valuable and
that's how you fund the operation
so here they need to fund it some more
so they just
inflate the currency um with the new
with the new token
and they project you know they project
that the network
is used it's going to be used
a lot more than double now so
i guess if you buy the new tokens
here phase two plan five years from now
there will be two billion instead of one
billion tokens my strong assessment is
that in this case the overall value of
the network in 2025 is going to be far
more than twice what it would be
if we didn't release the new token
so they need money they inflate the
currency
it's uh you know it's government um i
guess it's valid but
uh just just to be aware
okay that's the network um there are a
few crucial components
that i have left out now but that's
essentially
how it works so one crucial component
so here's the registry is where you
register
one crucial component is the reputation
system and this is something that's
quite you know difficult so the
reputation system is important because
if you want to
sort of find um agents
that that perform well you can also
sort of rely on reputation so if a lot
of people have
bought services from a particular node
in the past
and they rate it high then you can sort
of trust that node more than if
if a node is lower rated or has
dissatisfied customers
so they spent quite a bit here talking
about
reputation systems and how you could do
them and that is an open area
of research there's a really hard
problem to make
a good reputation system that can't be
gamed and so on
yeah there are various ways like for
example a stake deposited
by a consumer service owner to be
forfeited should its rating in some
dimension fall below
a given threshold so you can like
put some money and say well i i
if my rating falls below a three um
then that money is gone i will like it's
it's burned it's automatically burned
and that gives
people more trust in you because you're
now forced to uphold that
rating but it also allows some kind of
mafia games like you could go
to that you know service owner and be
like well it would be a shame
if you had a bunch of one star ratings
coming
in um then you can sort of
blackmail them in given circumstances so
it's not easy
right it's not easy but that's built
into
into it by the way because this is
on chain anyone can participate in the
market
permission less which is a really good
thing
um however they
maintain kind of a a dap a centralized
um platform where they that they control
so you you sort of have this
decentralized thing where everyone can
participate but only some people are
listed on the central on the main hub
let's say but you can technically build
your own hub like you could build
you can build your own android app store
and so on
so think of it like it's a marketplace
for apps
but only the ones that
are you know kyc compliant will be in
the
in the google app store but you can
build your own alternative app store
they also want to provide ai
infrastructure as a service and that i
feel it's really irrelevant like
they say okay we want to provide this
but it really doesn't matter
uh for the singularity net um
so they they here is where they go into
oh you could do this you can do that
with it and so on you can deploy it on
embedded devices so their idea is really
that the whole world will be connected
to this network and whenever you require
any sort of
functionality you just call the network
and
the network solves your problem as i
said i'm kind of doubtful
i still think it's probably going to be
people just build the functionality
either into a custom
you know uni service
or they uh they just build it on device
so the the last component here is
democratic governance
so they are they are invested in
in sort of making this a community
effort
and one thing is this governance right
how do you
govern a decentralized organization
and that is also an unsolved problem
they do it in multiple stages so they
stay say okay in years one and two of
network operation
basically the foundations the foundation
says everything
um in according to
any any major changes the foundation
decides
so the foundations are the maker of the
network in years three and four
um they transition so
major changes agreement of the
foundation plus a majority
agi holder votes um minor changes don't
actually
even require the foundation and then
there's also this introduction of
benefit tasks
um yeah so your stream four and from
year five on forward
um this the the foundation is gone
and only there it's only done by votes
or by agi
token holder votes which are logarithmic
such that rich people don't have
too much power um
yeah so this was launched in 2017 at the
end
so technically we are in this phase
right here
and i have searched for like an
announcement
that yeah we're going to transition from
this mode to this mode but i haven't
found it
on their blog instead of what i found
are like announcements that they're
going to they're going to launch this
supervisory council which are like
elected members that
check the foundation and also in this
roadmap of part two that we've just
looked at they
also saying oh progressive
decentralization making it real
they also talk about this supervisory
council and they now
pay them and they release uh financial
reports but nowhere does it say
that you see here it's 3.5 years in so
they should be
in that second phase maybe they are but
i would guess they'd make an
announcement
if that's the case maybe i've i've just
missed it and they're actually doing
this
but i have my feeling that
if you you know launch such a system
and you have power to do stuff and even
especially this if the system doesn't
grow as much as you expect and so on
you're not gonna give that power away so
that's
that is my my doubt here is that
if you have the power it's of course
it's always better for you if you say
well i'm just gonna hold on to it a
little bit longer
eventually you know when everything goes
well but
it's never that everything goes well
like
yeah hello communism
okay so enough rant um
the benefit tasks so they also have in
mind you see there's a lot of stuff
in this network right they also have in
mind that this
this network should benefit sort of
humanity as a whole
which is you know a laudable task but
they have a system
where it's some tasks are classified as
benefit
tasks and the these benefit tasks they
are
suggested by by agis by actors in the
network
that has so each agent gets a certain
number of benefit
votes right to cast each month based on
its benefit
rating so the rating system is
multi-dimensional and one aspect is
the benefit rating someone can rate you
beneficial if you like
do if your agi cures cancer or something
like this
um and then you nominate
you vote and then some
of the some money goes to
these benefit uh vote winners
once a qualified benefit decider
nominates a certain task
if 25 votes are cast in the affirmative
then the task becomes a benefit task
once a task is a benefit task any agent
capable of performing it and possessing
a sufficiently higher rating
and benefit rating will receive benefit
payment
for doing it okay so the idea is
the community nominates beneficial tasks
and these tasks will get
benefit payment the like the only
question is
where does this come from where does
that money come from
the benefit payment so
i guess it has to come from other people
so you have to have like some sort of a
benefit
tax or something like this that you of
other transactions that you give to the
benefit
uh tasks and then this is
like you the whole system works there's
nothing
about this that makes it benefit
specific you can
switch out the word benefit by evil
like some you have an evil reputation
and then some tasks are evil
and get evil votes and if you are
especially evil you get evil payments
um this whole notion rests on the fact
that people
somehow recognize what's beneficial uh
which is a highly highly controversial
right
and it's it's basically politics right
every politician
uh advertises themselves as beneficial
every
every you know organic food
is beneficial but then you just do the
bare minimum you like
cut you take 99 of tomatoes and you you
put a little bit of dirt on top of them
and boom they're organic like they're
now labeled as organic
it's it's i this is
to me this just seems like a thing
that's going
to be gamed so hard it's gonna become
irrelevant it's basically a political
game at this point
um because you cannot define benefit
other than
through human voting and human voting is
subject to money
and yeah that's how politics starts
okay so they have they have a
lot of examples so here you see sort of
this network idea
they have a lot of examples what
can be done with this i don't want to go
into into these because this video is
already quite long
but it's it's a lot of talk
i just want to say that it's a lot of
talk
and you know they're basically putting
up everything they have done
so far and they're doing on the network
what they can do with the network which
is all cool right
um it but it's it's sort of advertising
what kind of research they do on it and
uh
yeah the last point
the last point yes it's very long so
these people for some reason they
actually they're like two things they
love or three there's uh
graphs uh domain specific languages for
some reason they love graphs and domain
specific languages
so their idea of ai it all revolves
around
kind of classic notion of ai so there is
knowledge bases
and then there is uh graphs that and you
can see this reflection
in singularitynet right this idea that
lots of things by themselves network
together can make up a bigger ai and so
on that
is his exact reflection and exactly goes
counter to like the
deep learning idea of let's do
everything end to end
so the singularity net here is very much
a reflection of what these people think
and
yeah for some reason they love inventing
dsls for new problems
like why what like i've never understood
dsl aficionados but i guess if you're
having fun
okay so here they say measuring modeling
and
extending singularity net okay
so this is sort of their research on
singularity
net itself which is you know quite a
a important thing if you build a system
like this
but what i want to i wanted to do so
i've
read through all of this kind of
research suggestions and what they're
doing and it
it they just make it seem great
but it's also very washy
in my opinion and i was wondering is it
just because it's a white paper and i
you know
there's actual uh good research and for
most things i can
definitely guess you know they they're
you know they're also the people behind
this uh sophia
robot um i don't know if you you know
like this
sofia robot and so on they so they have
a lot of
success so precision medicine and so on
uh
there's a lot of research but some
things just sounded
uh also just washy so here that
this is something that made me
particularly just kind of stop
um so they want to measure
with this phi quantity for measuring
integrated information in complex
cognitive networks
so this phi this number five by this
researcher tontoni
is sort of a a measure fundamental
measure of the level of consciousness
and they themselves say you know maybe
it's not it's not you know
the measure but it's certainly an
interesting measure and so on and they
say we have experimented with measuring
phi across
time series generated by open cog by the
way open cog is from the
the same person that's one of the
co-founders ben gertzel
of singularitynet opencogs
attention allocation module yada yada
while the while the system parsed and
semantically analyzed a series of short
documents
we have also calculated phi values while
the open system controlled the
sofia humanoid robot
as she led a person through a structured
meditation
system so they like the extent of them
describing the research is simply
we have experimented with it and
we have measured it across time
and so i was wondering like what's
behind this so i went and i read
the paper that's linked there that's
this using
tontonify to measure the consciousness
of a cognitive system
while reading and conversing and
so this is a paper it's quite short but
they let it
read like texts from um
about different things and they measure
this phi
quantity and when you go and look first
what's this phi quantity
this is kind of a one of these papers
it's
it's very mathematical actually and
there's a lot of information
theory in there so it has something to
do with mutual information there's a lot
of ways you can calculate it as you can
see here on the left and there's a lot
of ways you can approximate it
so this is like a serious quantity uh
but measuring it is like super hard and
here
they let this open cog system read short
texts
with um with respect to as you can see
here
poison and insects and
they look where the sort of
i guess the attention the attentional
focus
of the system rests on which of these
concepts right and then they measure the
phi
over time and their claim here
is i was okay
we also calculated phi based upon the
concept nodes um
no wait up here as the system ingests
each sentence word nodes corresponding
to each word are simulated
stimulated with this system thus
triggering attentional focus dynamics
correlated with the
reading process one goal of the study
was to observe whether after reading
documents regarding insects
then poisons attention would spread to
the concept related to
ins to insecticide this phenomenon did
occur so they say okay
when you read when you read insect and
poison
after that you go you put a focus on
insecticide
and you can see so insect is blue poison
is
orange and you can see maybe
the insecticide you know bumping a
little bit
after when while you read poison
but honest like this could also just be
because it's associated with
poison um this is
you know i don't know that this is a bit
interpreted a bit too much into that
graph
and then what's even more astounding we
also calculated phi
values based on the concept node insect
poison and insecticide as figure 3
shows there was an interesting jump in
the phi
value when insecticide first became
important suggesting that the phi
increase
was correlated with an increased
complexity of attentional spreading
within the atom space
so the atom space and so on that's
that's sort of this classic ai concept
of
knowledge bases and atoms but here so
the claim is
that the phi on the right somehow
somehow correlates with the insecticide
attention on the left or with anything
interesting and that to me is a stretch
in fact i have
i've put the i've put these things
above one another so in the gray
background here you can see
uh the phi value and i've matched up the
the time steps right here and so the
claim is that
here insecticide marginally bumps up
and then sort of this phi spike is here
but if you look anywhere else like
here insecticide bumps up okay but
much delayed spike and here it doesn't
bump up at all but there's a spike still
and it's it just seems it just
like that is just not a a inference
you can make right here like
i'm i'm not sure let me let me know what
you think but
if you know you can't just nah
nah sorry this one you know this one
it was the one that that was kind of the
most
uh strange to me but
also yeah don't
uh don't don't tell me that this does
anything
but in any case they this is the the
type of research
uh that they do and um so they measure
these
measure the intelligence of the system
and so on
um yeah the last thing
is these what they want to do is this
offer net
economy and you know in researching this
paper i have also watched a bunch of
talks
from from ben and he seems like
sprawling with ideas
and the talk about these offer nets is
is
is also so the idea behind it is
that offernet is sort of
an economy without money the offernet's
domain model
where is it so
i don't i don't remember where it said
but offernet
is like an economy without money so the
idea behind it
is okay person a person b
person c or machines they are sort of in
an economy
and person a wants something that person
b
has but b doesn't want something that a
has
instead b wants something that c has and
c
wants something that a has and the logic
here is
couldn't you you know a cannot
a cannot trade with b b cannot trade
with c c cannot trade with a but they
can trade in a circle
right and this offer nets uh they do
make this possible and um
so the idea is sort of everyone puts out
there
what they want and the offer nets
they will sort of figure out um they
will figure out
who needs to trade with whom and thereby
you could make an economy
without money right without um
yeah you can make a money free economy
and uh is this the right paragraph
because there was a fun sentence there
was a fun sentence that i've i've seen
right here
um so
this is another another thing where i
think that just like the ideas they go a
bit
they go a bit too far um
offernets analyzing the data yada yada
opening the process okay i don't i don't
know where it was
but they say something like yeah
offernets could
mediate this process and um and how do
they mediate this process you know such
that everyone actually gets their worth
of stuff that they put out they mediate
this process by means of the
offer coin okay so the offer coin
is now transferred from b to a
um or sorry or from a to b let's say
because a1 something that b has and the
offer coin is transferred from b
to c and then from c to a so the offer
coin
makes all of this happen in an economic
sense
and like huh are you saying there is an
asset going along um with a certain
service
and the asset is sort of agnostic such
that you can
if b gets the asset from a b can then
give the asset to c in order to obtain
services from
c and that you know asset actually is
what makes the whole economy work even
though no one directly wants to trade
with each other
and you're doing all of that without
money
that's crazy so yeah
in any case i i think oh ah there we go
offernets a decentralized economy
providing an alternative to purely
currency based exchanges
this economy features a complex network
of interactions that optimizes
reciprocal changes of goods and services
by finding agents with compatible
and complementary preferences and
coordinating their interactions
dot dot dot by means
of a coin
which is money like that's
this is exactly what money does like
that that's what money is for
in any case i'm like this these people
are very smart
and i'm probably too dumb to see what
the exact difference
is uh right here so i i just
found it funny if you know if i'm
completely wrong
then let it be stated that you know
that's what a
uh semi-only semi-smart person would
conclude from reading these things all
right this was
lengthy um but i hope
you sort of got the idea the base system
is an a an api
marketplace now the api marketplace in
itself doesn't have
anything to do with um
ai necessarily but i've made the case
that the api marketplace only makes
sense
in the in the world of ai because if it
was
regular software you would just hard
code either the api calls or you would
actually
include the library so the marketplace
makes sense in the
realm of ai okay it it's doubtable
whether that's actually the case
it very much goes against the end-to-end
principle it bets on a form of ai
that works on on discrete graphs
it works on sub-components divided into
sub-components it works on
networks um networks built together
to achieve higher order functions it
could definitely be that the future of
ai lies in this direction it's just that
the current direction
is pointing away from that the whole
marketplace
runs in on the blockchain and
only the marketplace so the ai
processing is off chain
so it is not a on block chain ai
and yeah they've built it and they are
in money problems currently
they're inflating the currency but
they're switching blockchains
because they think the new blockchain
will be better and faster
and they project high growth and the
token is actually active
so it's you know it's not a dead project
and they are in the news quite a bit
especially uh with this this sofia robot
i think that is that is a very
it's a kind of a pr magnet all right
that was what i had to say
i hope you enjoyed it if you did share
it out let me
know what you think in the comments let
me know what i did wrong
and bye bye